une histoire beaucoup plus réconfortante
celle là elle nous ramène aux états unis
dans le new jersey une école propose à
ses élèves des enfants noirs de familles
défavorisées
un voyage à la recherche de leurs
racines et pour ce faire on leur apprend
le français correspondance de briller de
l'air se fondit est célèbre pour sa
misère son taux élevé de chômage et les
violences qui ont souvent opposé
communauté noire américaine à celle
immigrés des caraïbes
aujourd'hui ce torrent se fait connaître
par un programme scolaire original
presque révolutionnaire dans ce district
délaissé depuis la rentrée
130 des 500 élèves de l'école de nassau
ils sont tous noirs reçoivent un
enseignement strictement en français ici
on ne parle plus l'anglais même moment
traditionnel en amérique de prêter
serment à la constitution par des
instituteurs bilingue tous originaires
de pays francophones
ces cours élémentaire oblige les enfants
à découvrir un autre monde
mais alors apporte surtout un bagage
culturel supplémentaire que nous fournit
des renseignements traditionnel
américain qui peut favoriser biya passe
on n'offre pas ça aux enfants et
malheureusement que vous arrive à
l'université ils ont des difficultés à
s'adapter à la paix par des ce jeune âge
ils pourront mieux évoluer quand il
arrive à des niveaux plus élevés
en fait l'idée mise en pratique dans ce
collège est toute simple
en apprenant le français les enfants se
rapproche de la culture africaine et
peuvent simuler leur négritude
c'est la théorie de roosevelt weaver
principal du collège faux ferrand il y a
trente ans au sénégal
l'objectif et 12 leur apprendre à se
respecter mais aussi les préparer aux
futures car on le sait le monde se
rétrécit et des cultures différentes se
retrouvent en contact après deux mois de
cours les résultats sont plus
qu'encourageants
le programme devrait donc être
généralisé dès l'année prochaine à
l'ensemble du collège
et puis ils sont plutôt touchant ses
bambins américains qui roulent une
faiseuse y apprennent avec autant
d'ardeur à planter leurs choux à la mode
de chez nous retour en france